This episode is sponsored by Skillshare.
You need wood fire to ignite, you need auto oil to move,
And you need food to support every aspect of your life.
So what happens to your body if you suddenly stop eating?
To understand what happens to the body without food,
First we need to understand what happens when you eat.
The process begins from the sun, which gives its energy to photosynthesis and plants,
Then we consume that stored chemical energy,
Either directly by eating plants such as tomatoes,
Or by eating an animal, such as a chicken that feeds on herbs and grains.
If we take the hamburger as an example
You will absorb fat from fat-filled sauces,
A protein of beef,
And carbohydrates from a slice of bread.
Then your digestive system uses several processes such as chewing, stomach acid and enzymes,
To break the food into particles small enough so that you can absorb it into the bloodstream.
Excess glucose is stored in the liver and muscles in the form of glycogen,
While some are converted to fat.
You can visually see some fat stores in those fat parts of your body.
There are about 37 trillion cells in your body,
These cells begin to collect energy from food and put it into the mitochondria.
This is where the glucose and fat cracking has been to the acetyl acetate A.
Then start the citric acid cycle,
Where they are continuously rotated to release large amounts of energy carrying the particles.
The energy of these molecules is then used to pump protons,
In a layer of mitochondria becoming dense and surrounded by protons,
Making it need to deploy in a less crowded area,
It does this through a protein called adenosine triphosphate.
As a result, adenosine triphosphate, the most important source of energy in your body,
You use about 10 âµ molecules of adenosine triphosphate every day.
When adenosine triphosphate degrades adenosine diphosphate in your body,
The bond is broken and energy is excreted. The detachable energy helps several things, such as electrons that form bonds,
Essentially, you support all aspects of your ability to live.
If you stop eating, within 6 hours your body will break down glycogen into glucose,
The fat will be broken down into acetyl A, and this is done to maintain vital processes,
This is very normal, but after 72 hours,
Your body will need to break down protein to create glucose from amino acids,
Otherwise your brain will starve.
This happens because the fat used for energy can not cross the blood-brain barrier,
Since a person does not consume vitamins and minerals, people may get sick within a week.
After several weeks of hunger, fat stores are depleted,
All that remains of energy is protein.
At this point basic proteins are used to survive, such as antibodies used to fight infection,
Or muscle proteins used for strength - will be used by the body to make glucose.
The loss of essential proteins may lead to serious diseases.
Death may approach a rate of up to three weeks to 70 days,
Usually a heart attack due to deterioration of the tissues in the heart, diaphragm and body.
One factor in the length of your life is the extent of your body's moisture,
As well as the number of stores fatty.
Although it is amazing to think that you may stop eating this day,
And that she is likely to live for another 70 days,
But please, do not try this at home.
If you love nutritional knowledge then you should check out Skillshare
Who supported this video and offers a free trial for two months
To our first 1,000 subscribers.
Skillshare is an online forum for creators
With more than 17,000 chapters in design, photography, and even cooking and cooking courses.
Anyone can take a class, test a project, and even grade himself
With a premium membership of up to $ 10 per month for unlimited access.
Just go to the link in the description, even on the mobile app
Subscribe to more weekly science videos every Thursday.
Translating team translating translate autrjim @